[Musique]
du four à chaud de l'étan Salé il ne
reste qu'un morceau une tour réduite qui
a toutefois une nouvelle vocation celle
de club de tennis
municipale derrière c'est la calme chiic
rue du même nom mais au fait à quoi il
servait avant ce four à chaud le four à
chaud d'étin salé si j'ai bon souvenir
je crois que ça servait à faire des des
briques à partir de Roch calcire à faire
de la cha à partir des corau de la mer
on les fa chauffer et on obtenait donc
cette Chau y la la ch vive la ch morte c
un petit peu la JAV de l'ancien temps
pour PE et puis can pour le
blanchissement du
[Musique]
sucre
ce four d' Robin construit en 1922
appartient à la dernière génération de
four à chaud car dès le début de la
colonisation les maîtres maçons dépêchés
par la Compagnie des Indes bâtirent avec
de la
Chau ancêtre du ciment la Chau était
obtenue par toréfaction des corom mors
dans de haut fourneaux de
Pierr les premiers engagés indiens du
début du 18e apportèrent leur
savoir-faire et la qualité du mat
s'amélior
notablement mais c'est au 19e siècle que
l'usage de la Chau atteint son apogé
l'industrie sucrière qui en intégrait de
grosses quantités à la fabrication du
sucre abandonna progressivement son
monopole au profit d'authentiques
artisans
chaufourniers les usages de la cha
étaient variés désinfection des
poulaillers endu pour les mur engrais
pour les champs et bien sûr matériaux de
construction la construction des btim
administratifs du chemin de fer et du
port de la Pointe des Galé entraînèrent
un véritable pillage des madrports du
lagon la vingtaine de fours à chaud se
situaient en effet sur la côte ouest
ouvriers et pêcheurs employaient la
baramine et un radeau appelé zingade la
récolte séchait sur la plage avant de
partir vers les fourneaux l'arrivée du
ciment et un arrêté de 1969 interdisant
la pêche du corail dans les lagons mit
un terme définitif au travail des
chaufourniers
[Musique]
બે